well good evening Orlando welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored have you ever
heard of Mr Beast what about PewDiePie
how about keemstar Logan Paul Jake Paul
the answer might well be no you haven't
heard of them but if you've got kids
you will definitely have heard of them
and they most certainly have they're
just a tiny handful of the legions of
digital personalities whose videos are
viewed by literally billions of young
people across the world their
endorsements are worth millions in sales
their opinions can instantly reshape
conversations in schools universities
and across social media they're more
influence than most musicians soap stars
sports stars columnists lawmakers but
unlike those power Brokers of the past
the politicians and cultural stars who
can set the social agenda these people
seem to exist in a parallel universe
their views go largely unchallenged
shared only as bite-sized Clips they're
digital businesses often operate beyond
the scrutiny of normal journalists and
even Regulators they will massive
influence over young people and they're
restricted only by the ever-changing
whims of big tech companies it makes no
more sense the senators or secretaries
and state simply never appearing on
television well my guest tonight is a
perfect case in point an example of both
enormous Digi digital conquest and the
risks that come with it is Andrew Tate
his last interview with me has so far
been viewed or over 8 million times on
YouTube Alone 17 million times across
all platforms which is staggering for
someone who perhaps you're watching and
thinking who is Andrew T
it was a robust Exchange
and Andrew hertape was here because it
affected me being kicked off the
mainstream internet for supposed
misogyny his terrains against women were
viewed literally billions of times well
the first time around I wanted to find
out if he deserved to be banned and if
he'd ever actually crossed a line from
shocking opinions to genuine hate speech
or if he just didn't fit the ideal model
of the platforms that censored him
let's go through some sure right do you
think women are the property of men no
the point why have you said they are
because I made a religious Point
Authority implies that you have the
ability to control someone now Authority
believes the authority implies I have
the moral right to sit and say that
that's an irresponsible thing to do and
I'm responsible that's not what
Authority means I don't interrupt you I
just want to point out that's not what
Authority means if someone gives you can
a person can get voluntary Authority is
not Authority no but that's the point
and this is the thing that's interesting
Pierce please let me finish again like a
politician but hang on you could say I'm
interrupting you do but you're answering
a different question to the one I asked
you fine no no the more weaponizing the
weaponizing that doesn't exist no
problem if someone comes to me and says
I'm clinically depressed or I feel very
very sad I would say the first thing you
need to do is stop accepting the
identity of a clinically depressed
person stop accepting you have no
control over this Andrew You're simply
wrong
if that's what you believe Pierce that's
what I believe I don't believe in things
that take power away there is not an
eminent doctor in the world would agree
with this I think you know more than
doctors I can't become clinically
depressed
why do you know because I don't believe
in it
it's a lively stuff I also wasn't sure
if I should be interviewing him at all
if he was so unpleasant as so many
people said but why extend his profile
and give him a platform but the fact is
that that ship had already sailed every
teenage in the country knows Andrew Tate
it's just a lot of the parents who don't
and since that interview Andrew has been
returned to Twitter his new owner Elon
Musk is determined to perfect Protect
free speech online many young people
especially boys have literally stopped
me in the street since that first
interview to ask me about Andrew Tate
I've been staggered Honestly by the
response that I've had what does it say
about society that people like Andrew
take and reach so many more people than
conventional stars or journalists even
who gets to decide where the line is and
whether people like Andrew take cross it
are they part of a poorly understood
movement the pandas to teenage rebellion
like punk rock or pornography or are we
exposing young people to new and
damaging experiences we often don't see
and don't understand it's a whole new
world there are more questions about it
than answers and we're not going to
answer them by pretending it doesn't
exist well Andrew Tate joins me again
now Andrew good to see you salam alaikum
appearance good to see you I I've
genuinely been Amazed by the reaction
I've had in the streets not just here
but I went to Qatar for the World Cup
had the same thing there a lot of people
coming up about because John Ronaldo
obviously but also a lot of people
coming up about you and they were almost
exclusively men young men who genuinely
see you as a role model as somebody who
inspires them as somebody they want to
be like yeah so it made me think the
first interview you had was quite
combative the second time a short
interview less so I want to try and work
out in this one who you are because it
struck me as extraordinary that Google
this week revealed some stats for the
year the number one person whose name
followed people Google searching who is
in 2022 was Andrew Tate yeah that's
quite remarkable I think there's a whole
swath of the population especially young
men that feel disenfranchised they feel
disenfranchised with the media machine
and the things they're supposed to
believe they don't feel an affinity with
the Educational Systems or the culture
and they look at a person like me who
stands up and says the things that many
young men think I haven't put a magic
spell on the world the fact that people
like what I say means that they agree
with me deep inside they may be afraid
to say it themselves but I am seen as a
Bastion of free speech and a Bastion
Bastion from masculinity as a whole
because a lot of men are largely
forgotten about do you think you're a
Force for good or are you a force in
evolution
where perhaps you've done unsaid stuff
you shouldn't have done and as you get
older perhaps as you get bigger more
follow around the world you sense a
responsibility perhaps you didn't have
early on well we all evolve every human
evolves day by day you wouldn't be human
if you didn't evolve on an hour-by-hour
basis but I do not think I'm a Force for
good I absolutely not really know I am a
Force for good because I'm a force for
truth and truth is a good thing without
truth we're going to end up in absolute
tyranny in slavery and we're already on
our way there I feel like we're starting
to combat it my cancellation was the
beginning of a change in public
Consciousness Elon having Twitter is
another beginning of the change in
public Consciousness and anybody who
stands up and speaks what they truly
believe even if it's something I don't
personally agree with I think that truth
is absolutely important and people's
personal truths and people's personal
opinions even on differing sides of the
same opinion should be heard
tell me about your life you were born to
a mixed race uh couple your father was
an African-American a chess player yeah
uh and your mother she was from this
country correct yeah so my father was
was black chess player he was in the Air
Force he met my mother here in England
and then I was raised initially in the
United States and then I moved to Luton
England when I was younger so I've moved
around a lot I've lived uh eclectic life
in many different scenarios we've moved
around I've done a lot of different
things lived a lot of different
experiences and uh yeah well I mean
would you identify I consider myself
British now but I will say that part of
me the Patriotic Britain side of me is
devastated by the state of the UK
currently and I want to make that very
clear the Patriotic Britain me truly
loves this country and seeing what's
happening to it especially to our major
cities is almost heartbreaking to watch
in real time in what way it's falling
apart this is a failed Society by every
metric you can possibly measure it is
absolutely not really failing the cost
of living crisis the crime rates
everything is falling apart if you
compare it to a country tree like the
United Arab Emirates you compare it to a
city like Dubai London which should be
the greatest city on earth is failing in
absolutely every metric because our
leadership is a joke if you look at
Dubai in the UAE the leadership there is
so Flawless so genuinely genius they saw
ahead and built almost a Utopia and then
you look at London you can't walk around
with a watch on it's disgusting you know
it's very interesting I was in Qatar for
the World Cup obviously a lot of people
in England taking a very sensorious
moral view about the World Cup being in
the Middle East at all because of their
laws against homosexuality because of
their treatment of Migrant workers I've
got to say not that I don't share the
concerns about those things of course I
do but I found a lot of The Virtue
signaling and I think that's what it was
in many cases about the whole region
actually quite distasteful because when
I was in Qatar
a I thought the World Cup was
fantastically well run an incredibly
good experience but a lot of qataris
were saying to me you know there's this
weird quaint feeling back in your
country that we'll want to Aspire to
behave like that that we all want to
live in a country with massive drug
problems with massive knife crime issues
with scenes like the European
championships final where it's complete
lawlessness going on
um where
stuff like the NHS the system of
healthcare is basically collapsing where
the education system is dropping behind
so on and so on and so on it's a really
interesting perspective they were like I
know you all think that we want to have
your form of democracy in your form of
life but actually we're fine thanks
absolutely because it's a failed society
and it's Godless I think it's disgusting
we leave our old people to rot in old
people's homes and then we sit there and
say we don't have enough money for
nurses I understand this nurse strike
very well on how frustrating it can be
if you walk into a hospital and a nurse
is not prepared to work but the nurses
would be prepared to work at the current
wage if they believe this country was
spending his money prudently when you
see this country spending its money and
just absolutely wasting it pulling out
of thin air to fund proxy wars God knows
where that has nothing to do with them
of course as a nurse you're going to
stand up and say well can I get a pay
rise this country has failed on every
metric and especially our major cities
I've just come to London now I made it
very clear to my private jet pilot I
said fuel the Jet and leave it running
because the second I'm finished talking
appears I'm leaving this assessment it's
disgusting this country and London as a
whole 10 years ago was one of the most
hospitable cities on Earth now you
cannot walk around safely with a watch
on and you're a full-grown man you're a
full-grown adult when's the last time
there's been a serious problem in your
life that you completely ignored and it
fixed itself never ever what are any of
our politicians doing to fix any of the
problems we're doing today the Sadiq
Khan is planning to run again with a
third term of offices mayor all I can
say is I just everyone I know who's had
any experience of crime at any level in
London in the last few years has had a
bad experience of it of the way it's
been handled you know I mean I can give
an example I can reveal this now I've
talked for 18 months I've got a specific
death threat on one of my son's
Instagram pages in public a public
comment and it was very specific about
what this person was going to do I
couldn't use the police to evade him we
we know where you live we're going to
come and kill you and then the second
one threatening uh my son and his mother
my ex-wife I called in the police I'm
not having them putting death threats on
my sons I called the police police
investigated this they arrested somebody
over a year ago and then I heard from
the police this week that despite 18
months of Investigation of a publicly
posted comment on Instagram threatening
to kill me uh on my son's Instagram that
they will not be able to pursue the case
now I thought imagine I'm high profile
this was a front page of the Sun
newspaper if that same man called a
transgender person the wrong pronouns he
would be in trouble right so doesn't it
just show Absolutely how absolutely
asinine and banal our legal system has
become that would never happen in a
country like you never United Arab
Emirates the place I'm now residing in
Dubai where the leadership has common
sense and I'm saying that all the
leadership structures doesn't matter if
it's labor or conservative across all of
it in this nation of completely he
failed Sadiq Khan is a loser because
when you have a city which is losing
which London is is losing and all very
in all metrics across its competitive
cities around the world and you're in
charge of it by extension you're a loser
I will tell you right now instead of
virtue signaling and giving Qatar a hard
time over their religious beliefs what
we should be doing is a treaty with
Qatar to build a prison deep in the
desert give me make me mayor of London
we'll make a prison deep in the desert
and if you're caught with a knife or
robbing someone you can go do 25 years
with one meal a day in the in the
scorching sun and then what we'll do is
we'll put cameras there and we'll
interview you once a week and broadcast
that out to the nation and see if you
change your mind and make people
understand that this is a country that
should be respected and our law should
be respected instead what happens what a
city or any of the people in charge of
this country actually done to fix any of
our issues besides sit around and talk
nothing none of them have done anything
but they seem Ultra concerned with
finding money for proxy wars Ultra
concerned with rainbow Flags in another
country that is uninterested in them and
their priorities are completely messed
up of course the ambulance people are of
course the ambulance drivers are
striking of course the nurses are
striking nobody cares about the most
important things in this nation it's a
failing country in real time and that's
why I've left what about the specific
allegation by the way I don't disagree
with a lot of that um because I do think
this country is in big trouble and I do
think that one of the problems is people
think if they do have a crime against
them nobody cares anymore I know I know
nobody cares I can I have specific
examples and people who I know
personally absolutely and utterly nobody
cares I was in herod's yesterday and
someone tried to Rob someone's watch in
the middle of the store I walk around
with six full growth I have a security
team of six full-grown men plus me and
my brother eight military age males all
over 110 kilos big men just so I can
walk around this city it's absolutely
unacceptable
what about the issue of race and I
mentioned that in the context of the
Harry and Megan ongoing debate their war
with the royal family war against the
monarchy their specific uh constant uh
referencing to the fact that they
believe they were driven out of here
because of racism in Britain what do you
make of that debate that that's absolute
fallacy and you're from a mixed race
correct background yourself correct I'm
from a mixed race background myself and
while we're discussing the leaders of
the UK although I do think they're doing
a terrible job it's kind of hard for
Megan to say that the UK is a racist
country when the leader of the UK is
darker skinned than her and the mayor of
London is darker skinned than her and I
am a person who's probably darker
skinned than her and I've never
experienced any kind of bigotry against
myself besides the fact I'm a straight
male I'll get bigotry for that before
I'll get bigotry for my skin color I
think it's just a cop out and her not
wanting to be perspicacious and
self-reflective enough to understand
that she has attacked an age-old
institution and there are people who are
very patriotic about that institution
and by attacking it and bringing a
degree of distaste to it don't like her
and if you're a dislikable person you
can't just instantly stand up and say
it's because of my skin color it might
because be because of your actions and
some of the things you've said I mean I
think there's probably no doubt she said
racism on social media because who
hasn't it's a successful you probably
have well as I said to sell I've had
death threats on social media no no one
seemed to care very much um but I I
think that's probably inarguable my
issue with what they've both been doing
is if you're going to make allegations
against an institution like they're all
family and the monarchy you've got to
actually provide some evidence you can't
just spray gun this thing out there and
say well somebody was racist yeah and
airing dirty laundry is never going to
be respected by the populace and being a
tattletail is never going to be
respected by the populace and I think
the problem with the modern world we're
living in is a lot of age-old traditions
are being destroyed in real time it
doesn't matter what the tradition is
most of them are being eroded and
something like the British royal family
which has been around for a very long
time is an age-old tradition one of the
things holding the UK together one of
the last things we have to sit and
detriment it and to sit and insult it
and to give way secrets from inside of
it and try and paint a negative image of
it is going to upset a lot of people and
you have to be prepared for that
backlash you can't say I've done things
to upset people but it's nothing to do
with what I've done it's purely because
of my skin color also it's kind of
ironic that she's doing that because
she's not particularly dark skinned it's
kind of funny to sit her sit here sick I
mean
I think the truth is I don't know what
look you can say that I can't
um the reality of it is I just don't
know what the specifics of the racism
she says she's had because we've not
seen any evidence the universe is a
funny Place appears if you're looking
for something you're going to find it
right when I got canceled when they
attacked me unfairly lied about me
across the entire mainstream media
deleted me from social media so I
couldn't defend myself and lied about me
repeatedly I could have stood up and
said it's because I'm Brown I didn't do
that I sat and said okay there's people
who misunderstand my message my message
is is a positive one people
misunderstand me let me self-reflect and
understand that yes perhaps this said a
long time ago was said in the wrong way
perhaps this was understood perhaps
people don't understand this I could
have just copped out and could have just
been refusing to self-reflect on any
level and said it's because I'm Brown
that's why they did it but that's not
the immature way to be as an adult what
did you think of the Jeremy Clarkson
Fury where he wrote well I think most
people but including him belatedly after
he'd published it and written the column
he did make an analogy from A Game of
Thrones uh scene which most people I
think did find across the line and was
deeply offensive I I think you've
crossed a line what do you think yeah I
understand why people feel that but when
you attack an institution as old as the
British royal family you're attacking
patriotism in and of itself for one of
the
most respected countries or previously
most respected countries on Earth and
you're going to have some visceral
reactions perhaps Jeremy Clarkson is too
famous and too well renowned to say
those kind of things but there's a lot
of people who genuinely feel that way
and that's why he said it and this is
what happens when you attack age-old
institutions on any country should he
ever apologize that's a good question it
looks like he did personally I think as
a man you should stand up say what you
mean mean what you say I don't think you
should ever apologize for anything
you've ever said even me what if you say
something truly then if it's very
offensive and you actually do regret it
if you truly regret it then yeah okay
you can apologize but if at the time you
meant it then the best thing you can do
is say look I have just changed my mind
I no longer feel that way but at the
time that's how I felt and I'm the
person who says what he feels and that's
what I felt at the time and I apologize
that offended you as you say we'll be
back with you after the break we'll talk
to you about Twitter again uh Elon Musk
retort restoring users platform has it
calmed you down are you as controversial
on there are you mindful that you're
only one false move like Kanye West for
example away from being removed again
but what Elon Musk has restored a strong
abandoned accounts just taking over
Twitter with a sworn commitment to free
speech it's also shown he has a line of
his own though conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones remains banned Kanye yay West was
reinstated then banned again for posting
a swastika inside a star of David Andrew
Tate is back two for now anyway he was
first removed in 2017 the saying women
should bear some responsibility as
victims of rape and he hasn't exactly
been shy since his reprieve let's take a
look
Genghis Khan had endless women and 200
children as a reward for Conquest he
tweeted on the most searched man on the
planet I've conquered Earth on the
highest status male on the planet
females do not expect loyalty from me
they only expect that of lesser men
then there was this imagine having less
than 10 children because you're a
who doesn't have four wives genetic
failures finally if a girl follows me
and she's hot and I see a single picture
of it a private jet it's block women
can't afford Jets women are all brokies
why are you flying around on some man's
jet you should have been a virgin when I
met you Haram all right Andrew Tate now
you're you're getting very near the
knuckle with some of those tweets am I
you tell me I don't think so I think
people can understand they're
semi-satirical I think people can
understand you mean them as jokes or do
you mean them don't I don't mean them as
jokes I mean they're a overall public
commentary and observation I do mean
what I say if I were to see a girl on a
private plane on Instagram for example I
would assume that a man put her on that
private plane I would not assume she
bought it herself well if it was perhaps
that makes me misogynistic what if it
was Ariana Grande or Beyonce well that's
slightly different isn't it why because
they're famous yeah of course and
they're famous and very rich
if I saw well if I saw a 19 year old
girl from Moldova where the average wage
is 200 a month and she was on a private
jet I would assume that with the balance
of probabilities considering I'm an
adult it's very likely because of her
beauty a man has put her on that private
plane yes if that makes me misogynistic
instead of just perspicacious enough to
understand how the world works so be it
I'm a realist should you be such a
generalist about these things well you
have to be a generalist when you're
looking for in the balance of
probabilities and tried to find balance
in the world you have to be a generalist
in general if I stroke a lion it's gonna
bite my hand in general there might be a
nice one but I don't want to find out so
that's how the world Works you've
praised the Taliban in the past would
you do so again tonight the world is not
black and white the world is gray it's
very difficult to sit and make black and
white assumptions about anything to sit
and say that the Taliban are completely
and utterly evil and we're completely
and utterly good as you just discussed
with the moral High Ground I believe
that the Taliban bring law and order it
may not be the Law and Order we like but
it's a form of Law and Order and humans
try usually gravitate what about less
treatment than women only tonight only
tonight they have banned any women from
going to University fantastic let's get
the feminists to go and teach them a
lesson the feminists are so tough and
they stand up and say they can do
anything a man can do let's arm them up
and send them to Afghanistan I'm sure
they'll fix it no but it's it's not it's
a it's a serious matter isn't it that
women don't that's education and that's
a very serious answer if women are just
as capable as men in terms of combat
like feminists pretend they are they can
go over there and they can deal with a
lot of women do go to combat well
exactly so they can go do all the
talibans nothing to do with me they can
stand up and fight for their own right
surely you wouldn't defend the Taliban
Banning women from University it's
saying it's nothing to do with me Pierce
it's absolutely nothing what about the
Afghan women it's nothing to do with me
on any level you don't have a view I
have a view my view is that people
naturally gravitate towards Law and
Order and if you didn't have the Taliban
you'd have different Warlords operating
in lawlessness and there would be no way
to prevent your store your Market stall
getting completely robbed by someone
with an AK-47 and people are going to
gravitate towards a form of Law and
Order America left they left a power
vacuum and the power vacuum is now full
well I don't disagree with that okay
well I do think I do think the Banning
of Women's University in Afghanistan is
utterly horrific and I think the
feminists are going to arm themselves
they're going to show us that they can
do anything a man can do they're going
to go over there to combat they're going
to teach child of adolescents why can't
you just say on that you know what it's
completely wrong because it's not my
point it's I don't understand but it
makes you mean it makes me think it'll
make your critics think that you don't
think it's wrong they could ban all men
they could ban all sure but they're not
they're only Banning women correct they
could ban all short people they could
ban all people with long hair and not if
it's anything to do with me so they can
do whatever they want I'm not couldn't
go to war with the Taliban but you've
just literally spent an impassioned
first segment comparing the way for
example Dubai handles Law and Order
correct to this country correct so you
do Express views about different laws
absolutely both places so when I put to
you a law that basically bans women from
being educated it's not why is it a
problem for you to say you know what
it's wrong there are both places I've
resided in Dubai London so I have
personal experience I can give my
personal opinion but like I said there's
absolutely nothing to do with me with
what the Taliban decide to do inside of
Afghanistan and they decide that's the
most prudent way to run their society
then we have two choices we can either
go over there and start another war that
we shouldn't be involved in and waste a
bunch of life or we can sit and say it's
up to them they should govern themselves
there are people we're no better than
them and they've decided to live their
lives a particular way and that's how
they're going to live it like I said if
feminists are very upset and they're
very disgusted by the fact that in
Afghanistan women cannot go to school
I've been told repeatedly by feminists
that they're just capable as men in all
Realms and I expect them to arm
themselves and fly over to Afghanistan
and fix it like a lot of women have done
in combat I'm good congratulations go
fight
well this is the thing that's very
interesting because when you talk about
ideas it's not even just about
Afghanistan and feminism you talk about
ideas they must all be defended at some
point there has to come down to violence
the world is backed by violence nobody
wants to talk about this it doesn't
matter what it is if you have a
disagreement between two parties
eventually if the disagreement continues
it ends up in violence feminism is
defended by men men stand up and defend
feminism not feminists themselves
because they're incapable of violence
and we're in a situation now where
you're saying that we should send men to
go and fight for feminism why it's not a
man's problem
I think well hey I think men can be
feminist too because if feminism
believes in equality for women
I don't agree with radical feminists who
hate men right they do to me the radical
anything to me is a bad thing yeah and I
think most feminism in the west
currently is radical
well some of it is no question
absolutely but that's my point my point
is that with the Taliban are going to do
whatever the Taliban decide to do if I'm
going to fly over to another country I
will respect their laws and customs it's
not my job to come along and tell other
people how to live I don't believe I
have a moral High Ground in that degree
and if people are genuinely upset and
disgusted by it the bottom line and most
disagreements from the earth is violence
people who feel like they should go and
fix it then fix it with violence then it
can be the feminists who feel so
outraged by it but it's funny they don't
comment on these subjects feminists they
seem to instead attack the Western male
for some reason you deleted a video in
which you praised Isis why I don't know
which video you're talking about in
particular it might have been a video
from a long time ago but in general I
understand that like I said the world is
not black and white the world is gray
areas and Western imperialism as a whole
has been causing more problems and it's
ever fixed and it's disgusting and I
don't know the exact video You're
referencing but sometimes when an
underdog destroys a western imperialist
I have a degree of
I wouldn't say satisfaction but
everything satisfaction no but there's
there's certainly a degree of oh the way
Isis I don't know the particular I don't
know about the particular video we're
talking Isis were one of the most deadly
Terror groups in the world absolutely
they committed a series of appalling
atrocities sure killing innocent people
how could you possibly have satisfaction
well if it's the video I'm recollecting
if it's the video we're talking about
it's about the fact that I believe that
Isis was funded by the Western created
by the West in the first place and it
wasn't a degree of satisfaction like I'm
happy Isis exists it was a commentary on
the world well here's what you said Isis
are the real Muslims because I assist
exactly what the book says kill everyone
is not a Muslim and chop people's heads
off and set them on fire and be raging
lunatics but all the other Muslims go
they're not real Muslims because I read
the book and ignore those parts well
then you're not an effing Muslim because
you're ignoring the effing book
that's an interesting that's an
interesting point you've just raised
because I am now Islamic and it's it's
funny because I used to be an atheist
and when you're an atheist you believe
that religion causes more problems than
it fixes and then you come to a
realization and you start to learn the
truth of yourself and the truth of God
and you realize that religion is
actually the cure for most of the
problems in the world and godlessness is
the problem in the world so that is
something I will apologize for to me I
was wrong about because I was atheistic
and now as a Muslim I understand that's
absolutely not the case if that's a
particular video you're talking about
then then well that's really interesting
so you you regret saying that yeah
because you learn and you grow and you
evolve as I said at the time I believed
it because I didn't believe in God at
the time it was a very long time ago
it's actually kind of a testament to you
peers you managed to find the oldest
possible videos of me that have ever
existed but at the time I was atheistic
well no I was curious because you have
recently converted to Islam correct so
these questions are thinking pertinent
to your conversion absolutely as to what
you actually believe as a practicing
Muslim now uh yeah I believe that Islam
is beautiful I believe it's the last
True Religion on Earth it's certainly
the last respected religion on Earth and
I felt differently inside since I've
converted and I think it has the
solutions to a lot of the problems we're
facing in the world today
that particular video was once again
satirical a lot of people watching this
would not have seen it they would not
seen the joke element of it it's fine it
but it's not funny though well you know
it's like most of the time as we
discussed in our first interview with me
things are taken out of context short
form etc etc but
all in all you could say the same things
about Christians if you were to read the
Old Testament and say stick to the Old
Testament you'd kill anyone who works on
a Sunday so it's not applicable to you
wouldn't countenance violence say again
you don't countenance violence I
absolutely do not countenance violence
when I was talking about violence being
the bottom line salute the bottom line
decider between
disagreeing points of view it's not I'm
calling for violence I'm just making a
commentary on how the world genuinely
functions when you use a word like
satisfaction
you understand that people will watch
that and think how can you possibly find
any form of terrorism satisfying I don't
find any form of terrorism satisfying I
don't find Western terrorism satisfying
either I don't think it's satisfying
that we managed to find five hundred
thousand dollars per bomb to drop on
some farmer who makes four dollars a day
under the name of freedom and and we
can't seem to pay our nurses enough to
do their jobs I don't find any kind of
terrorism and it's actually very
interesting you talk about the world
terrorism terrorist and freedom fighter
good guy and bad guy all of this is
subjective there are people who believe
that the west of the biggest terrorists
on the Earth are people who believe that
America causes more Wars than anyone
else and they've killed more people than
anyone else and there's people who
believe the absolute opposite so once
again it depends who you're talking to
it's a subjective conversation there's
no black and white in the world there's
areas of gray and that's how it is so I
thought you were talking about another
video where I was saying that Isis is
standing up and fighting for what they
believe in I'm not saying what they
believe in is right but that's what they
were fighting for at the time and it was
a completely different video than the
one you were actually referencing but
you would condemn them now I don't
condemn anybody doing anything bad to
anybody I I'm not a person out here with
a criminal record I don't hurt anyone I
just spent my first
segment on this show talking about how I
believe in Law and Order and how
important that is I think people can
operate inside of their lives safely and
walk around man woman child can walk
around in safety in any City they live
in how that Law and Order is constructed
is not my
jurisdiction I'm not in charge of the
Law and Order of Afghanistan Tajikistan
Kyrgyzstan Afghanistan Kazakhstan any of
them there's nothing to do with me I
want to talk to you after the break
about masculinity why is it that so many
young men gravitate to you what is your
view of what it takes to be a man
welcome back to the special edition of
Piers Morgan on censored with Andrew
Tate one on one so Ash sarkar who's a
lively contributor to this program has
tweeted Andrew take or you're
interviewing about Free Speech thinks
women are a man's property we shouldn't
be allowed to drive both about only
dating teenagers to imprint on the
misogynists are discussing whether
they're an Afghanistan or a Swanky
London Studio
am I a misogynist am I I don't think I
first thing she said I don't even truly
believe it's I can if you're prepared to
listen to me I'll explain to you exactly
why she's not really completely utterly
wrong if you can go through the points
again do you think you're a misogynist
absolutely not I'm not a misogynist on
any level this is one of those buzzwords
they throw it and they just throw at
people randomly homophobic racist
misogynistics throw it out at people
what is your view of women I'm a realist
what's your real view of women I
absolutely not only love women I adore
women I have good relationships with
women not a single woman has come up to
me on the street since I've been
canceled not a single one has said
anything negative every single one of
them has said positive things you're a
traditional male I wish more men were
like you you understand your masculine
roles you understand what you're
supposed to do you understand you're
supposed to protect women you're exactly
the kind of man I'd be looking for I've
never had a negative interaction with a
female ever since I've been dubbed the
biggest massages where is the please
please let me finish I'm sorry sorry
Pierce also there's not been a single
woman who's accused me of a crime not a
single woman's accused me of rape not
single woman has come out and said
anything from my entire past of 36 years
I've done anything wrong ever anybody
else with my level of Fame any football
or any other movie star at least has
people who've come out and accuse them
of rape XYZ I have no woman who's come
out and ever said I've hurt her no woman
has come out and ever said I've done
damage to her or been horrible to her
everybody who ever interacted with me
has said I've been a nice person all of
them so this random Twitter nobody who
seems to know so much is full of all
right you've responded to her Twain yeah
where is the line for you between
masculinity which I will always defend
and which I agree with I think a lot of
women like men to be masculine and and
what has become known as toxic
masculinity and the reason I ask you is
that you are engaged in that debate with
men all the time where is the line for
you where men shouldn't cross where the
behavior should be kept within a line
please define toxic masculinity well you
tell me what you think it crosses a line
from being a masculine good man to a bad
man there's no such thing as too much
masculinity if it's genuinely masculine
genuine masculinity is not out here to
hurt people it's absolutely the opposite
is out here to protect and when bad
things happen they call traditionally
masculine men if you need a firefighter
you need a masculine man when you call
the police because of the problem you
have you want masculine men and as soon
as a woman or a man is in trouble when
you look for backup you look for
masculine men and masculine men have a
duty to provide and protect those they
care about we have a duty to do things
we don't feel like doing because we know
we're supposed to do them and that's why
we stayed in the Titanic and died those
were masculine where did you get your
views about this from because what I
grew up with is the family I grew up
around and the father your mother yeah
and the world I lived in and I think a
lot of the things I'm saying now about
masculinity and how people should act in
the world how the world should function
we're considered completely normal and
accepted by everybody only 20 years ago
I think the world's just lost its mind
for me to stand up and say a man should
protect a woman now gets to be called a
misogynist and canceled if I said that
10 years ago everyone would say duh and
what's funny is everyone who argues
against me it says men shouldn't protect
women especially all the feminists if
they were with their boyfriend and a man
broke into their house guess who they'd
expect to go downstairs
who do you think think they go
themselves are they going to Afghanistan
no we send men to do these things women
we send women in the armed forces too
would you have to generalize when you
make points there are many many
exceptions exceptions do not disprove
the rule no but they're you've got to
concede there are many courageous women
serving in the arms absolutely and
utterly completely correct but by and
large traditionally soldiers are men
exceptions do not disprove the rule
well it's not an exception it's the fact
that there are a lot of women on the
Armed Forces correct but if you were to
take the average Soldier they are a male
if you're allowed to say who's a male
and who isn't nowadays I'm assuming
their gender I apologize if you ever
take the average Soldier they're a male
which means that exceptions are the
female soldiers which because there's a
lower percent of them a lower
probability exceptions do not disprove
the rules men do the fight right now in
Ukraine men cannot leave women are
allowed to leave because men have to
fight in the front line and women are
allowed to go to Dubai that is how it is
what do you say to young men who come to
you for advice you feel lost you don't
really know where they fit into society
I say that life as a man is
exceptionally difficult I say them both
beautiful and the most terrifying thing
about being a manager born without value
Society doesn't care about you you're
only going to be cared about based on
how useful you are you have the chance
to build yourself up and become a
superhero if you're prepared to do the
hard work and be indeigable enough to
never quit but if you're going to stand
around and wait for a handout nobody's
going to ever respect you and I think
that a lot of people have forgotten
about how difficult and how competitive
it is as a man always in constant
competition with each other and it's
your duty as a man to stand up and say I
want to be as important and strong and
good-hearted and God-fearing as possible
and I need to work hard to achieve those
things David Sheila Hancock says we've
become too over emotional as a society
crying too much about everything yes
you've got a point she's completely
right and the dangerous thing about
overly emotional men is that they're
dangerous they're genuinely dangerous
this is what's crazy all these people
who talk about toxic masculinity and how
bad it is for men to be traditionally
masculine a traditionally masculine man
does things he doesn't feel like doing
but because it's his duty to do them he
charges into the burning building
because it is his duty not because he
feels like it because it is his duty
we're now teaching the new generation of
men that they don't have duty and they
can just act on their feelings and act
how they feel and they don't have to act
as a man should do you know what happens
when you get men who just act how they
feel you get School shooters you get
violence you get rapists men who do not
control their emotions are dangerous if
you find a man who is stoic he's not
going to hurt people he's going to sit
and think about his actions very
carefully and he's going to be a good
man who protects for it and provides for
his family you find a man who just acts
out on impulse and does whatever he
feels like you're going to find a
dangerous man sitting here telling men
to cry more and act with their feelings
and it's okay to feel this way that way
Etc and have no self-control that is why
we have the problems we have in the
world absolutely nothing wrong so when
they talk about toxic masculinity they
have it completely inversed on its head
completely nutly wrong we need to be
teaching stoicism we need to be teaching
young men to understand that the world
is very very difficult it's hard to be a
man you're going to feel bad sometimes
you just suck it up and perform anyway
not to sit there your cry your eyes out
or blame other people certainly
off being a woman but I'm not a woman so
why would I speak on issues I do not
understand I'm a man you can feel an
empathy for women I feel empathy
certainly but I do not understand their
issues a lot of men come up to me and
they admire you I've got to say a lot of
women I've spoken to don't admire they
think you represent misogyny they think
when they hear you not commit to saying
the Taliban shouldn't be banning women
from University education why can't he
just say that's wrong well firstly
that's not my experience I experience
the absolute and utter opposite of that
secondly it's because it's a moral point
I'm making my moral point is I speak on
things I understand I speak on
experiences I've had would you believe
in equality I speak yes sure I speak on
subjects I know intimately I do not feel
qualified I'm a realist and I do not
feel qualified to sit and discuss the
gender laws in Afghanistan I have not
been to Afghanistan I have not
researched the subject thoroughly I'm
not going to sit here and say how their
Taliban should be running their country
it's nothing to do with me I find it
quite flattering peers that although you
know I understand I'm monumentally
influential the most Google now on Earth
Etc I find it very flattering that you
think I have some kind of control over
the domestic policy of Afghanistan but I
assure you I don't I don't no no I'm not
asking you to have a view on having
influence of a domestic policy I'm sure
the Taliban couldn't give us stuff what
either of us say about it um it's just
curious to me that it's an easy win for
you to make women think you're not anti
them to say that when they're not given
a quality as the women in Afghanistan
clearly are not because they're not
allowed to go to university now as of
today that is clearly unequal unfair we
should all be able to agree that that is
wrong well certainly as a real even you
tough guy Andrew not tough guy I am a
professional as a professional I can
state that yes it is not equal yes it is
not fair that is obvious for anybody I'm
not saying those things are not true
what I'm saying is it's nothing to do
with me right okay but you've made a
concession you think is wrong it's wrong
I said it's unequal and it's unfair yeah
so wrong well perhaps force yourself
Andrew no perhaps it's wrong under
certain moral guidelines but under the
moral guideline lines which are
currently in charge of the jurisdiction
of Afghanistan they don't believe it's
wrong it's nothing to do with me well
then I'm not going to sit here and tell
other countries how to run their laws
I'm going to live in societies which you
know what I'll take unfair and unequal
sure because that's self-explanatory
we're going to have a game of chess in a
minute after the break because you are a
very good chess player I can hold my own
in the chessboard your father was a
chess uh International Master uh in fact
and we're gonna have a five minute game
of speed chess Winner Takes all Mr Tate
welcome back to Pittsburgh on Central
Andrew Tate is still here Andrew's
father was an American chess
International master and his son's
pretty good at it too well I can hold my
own that's my school chess champion and
with five minutes left on the program
we're gonna have a game of speed chess
when it takes all right but you're white
off you go
that's
racist peers cancel Piers Morgan okay
are you good Pierce well you're gonna
destroy me clearly from this opening
better than you
I guess uh okay let's be aggressive
shall we
School chess champion eh
it's tense
certainly Lennox Lewis was better than
you when I played him was he well he
beat me 39 times out of 40 check yeah he
is uh pretty good at the game I heard
time to get aggressive with you Mr Tate
show you a bit of toxic chest
masculinity well
the world's been pretty aggressive with
me lately Pierce so uh I'm used to it
it's fine
okay
thank you
oops apologize
why do you think the queen for a 45 why
do you think the queen gets to jump
across the board and the King doesn't
because he's sexist
a game of Chester Sexes but perhaps it
reflects life peers haven't you ever
thought that when you look at a yacht in
Dubai you're running out of time stop
stalling oh God I'll stick your queen
damn it I was trying to give you a
little speech there you didn't want to
listen to it when you see a yacht in
Dubai the girl who just gets an
Instagram invite gets to jump right on
board listen run across the board and do
whatever she wants but the man is to get
there a square a Time the man had to buy
that yacht that's the difference between
being a man and being a woman that's why
the queen you know what she does a
chivalrous man just always lets ladies
go first life and chest life and chess
reflect peers
I've met a catastrophic error but I'm
bouncing back
let's see
I always accidentally take someone's
check three minutes I don't even mean to
it's just like oops
didn't even stop knocking my pieces over
like some
Thug yeah exactly
he's not getting in my head
they're talking to me saying you're
getting in my head
um
how do you think chess reflects life I
think that it's all about strategy
correct that if you're good at chess you
can be good at pretty much anything
because it's about thinking ahead it's
about planning it's about Relentless
practice and you know what else is
beautiful about chess if you lose
somewhere you made a mistake there is no
luck absolutely right and chess even if
it's the smallest mistake somewhere it
was your fault it teaches absolute
self-accountability which is something
that we need a lot more of in the world
today no it's true and that's why chess
is so important you can take my knight
if you want you don't want it
uh because I'm playing a long game oh
okay
I thought you'd want it I'm gonna leave
it there in case you take it anyway okay
I'm gonna go because I know what you
want me to do I'm not gonna do it
actually I will do it now okay good
check
check
how long I need to buy some time here
I need to buy some time
uh
this is really playing well on Radio by
the way
damage
uh
I'm screwed
I'm screwed
I will say that how long have I got one
minute believe in yourself I never ever
give up believe in yourself I do believe
myself thank you good self-belief is
important I do believe myself but this
has not gone well you're quite good at
chess I'll give you that yeah well in
the chessboard of life I've done pretty
good
um I've done okay
check the question is can you beat me in
time you've only got 50 seconds check
that's interesting yeah I don't think
you can we'll see uh
um mating two piers
yeah you can have that doesn't matter
it's mating two check
good game sir well played thank you 25
seconds away from safety
okay well as you say I'll give you
something uh you get a chess thank you
you have to be you just beat me
I know you're a national internationally
what does chess talk to you about life
quickly I can teach you a lot of things
like I said about the queen being able
to run around the board the king having
to move a square at a time about the
fact you need to think ahead absolutely
everything is your fault but there is a
saying which is actually one of my
favorite sayings in the world that said
a well-gamed a well-played game of chess
is a sign of a gentleman but an expertly
game expertly played game of chesses to
sign up a wasted life and it's kind of
sad I put the links Lewis in on
Celebrity Apprentice 39 times out of 40
in America years ago and he he beat me
39 times out of 40 of me uh and I was
amazed he was taught by his mum but he
was all about the way he fought the way
he boxed was all down to the way he
played chess yeah it was all about
looking ahead getting ahead of your
opponent planning planning punches you
know all that kind of thing just
absolutely reflects life and even I say
this now in my business meetings with my
team a lot of the problem in the world
today especially with teams and
businesses Etc everyone wants to be the
king but if you want to have a team if
you want to have a side that wins if you
want to win a game of chess everybody
has to know their role and do their role
effectively there can be a king and a
rook and a pawn a bishop up in the night
and everyone does everything correctly
and when that happens you have a very
formidable board and you're hard to be
and uh chesterflex life absolutely is
something I do every single day what
kind of man was your father
he was the greatest man on the face of
the planet but uh luckily he had me and
now in the natural order of the universe
he's gone and I am here and I carry his
name and it is my duty to bring honor to
him and this is one of the greatest
things about achievement because
achievement honors your ancestors people
talk about my father because of how
successful I am and people will talk
about me into eternity even after my
death because of how successful uh my
son will be this is the great thing
about achievement it's an honor to your
ancestors what would you have made of
your success your father he would be
extremely
underwhelmed by it because he always
expected it of me I am Emory Andrew take
the third I can do whatever I put my
mind to and he would be like well of
course you decided you want to become
the most famous man on the planet it
took you a few months of course does
your does your mother ever do what my
mother does occasionally go I think you
went too farther my mother has absolute
trust in my abilities and capabilities
she says be careful do your best but you
are the most capable and competent man
on the planet that wasn't the question
that that's what she says she says be
careful does she ever say you shouldn't
have said that nah she knows better than
that really come now never she says
you're just be careful you know what
you're doing it's kind of hard to argue
against me and this is what my haters
seem to struggle with it's hard to argue
against the person who is monumentally
successful in every single human metric
that can possibly be measured this is
why young men respect me so much would
you ever tell your mother they want to
be my life you ever tell her what to do
I don't need to she's a full grown woman
would you ever tell her what to do I
would give her my advice if she asked
first you say you can't leave the home
you can't drive all those things you
joke about I would give her my I'd give
her my opinion I would say perhaps you
should move house now or perhaps that's
not safe or yeah I would absolutely
because I'm responsible for her safety
and when you're responsible for
somebody's safety you have an opinion
and you need to have a firm opinion on
that subject so completely for any woman
I am responsible for for any woman I'm
responsible for her safety I will sit
and say that's an unsafe thing to do how
much are you worth
I'm a billionaire by now dollars or
pounds about dollars we're not in pounds
yeah but we'll get there so what to do
yeah we have a little bit of work to do
but finally I know you don't know
anything about football and carry the
list but greatest of all time Ronaldo
and Messi they're both two very
hard-working men I have absolute respect
for anybody on Earth who dedicates
themselves
Andrew Tate thank you very much indeed
that's it for tonight keep it
unsensitive like it was tonight